vamos a sumar algunas expresiones
racionales más sumemos 1 entre x
cuadrada menos 9 con con 2 entre x
cuadrada más 5 x + 6 entonces justo como
lo hicimos cuando aprendimos a sumar
fracciones o bien números racionales
tenemos que tener un denominador común y
en este caso lo que esto quiere decir es
que queremos encontrar el mínimo común
múltiplo de estas dos especiales de aquí
y cuando digo esto pues bueno vamos a
acordarnos un poquito supongamos que
queremos sumar un cuarto con un sexto y
pues sabemos que un cuarto es 1 entre 2
por 2 y que un sexto un sexto es uno
entre dos por tres
entonces para poder sumar estas dos
expresiones necesitamos tener un
denominador común ya tenemos 2 aquí
debemos tener un 2 que está por allí y
para que podamos meter el primer término
en el denominador común quitamos otro 2
entonces el denominador común necesita
tener un 2 que está
haciéndose cargo de estos dos estamos
otros dos para este dos de aquí dos más
dos por dos y necesitamos también un 3
este 3 lo ponemos también por acá
tenemos que tener todos los factores
primos de aquí pues para que tengan un
denominador común entonces pues ya
tenemos los 2 12 y 13 y entonces nuestro
mínimo común múltiplo queda dos por dos
por tres que es 12 después de esto
podríamos seguir sumando con el método
para sumar fracciones ya que tenemos un
denominador común podemos haber
multiplicado 6 por 4 pero va a quedar
más grande y al final hay que hacer
algunas cuantas simplificaciones pues
mejor lo dejamos así la mismísima idea
la podemos aplicar aquí lápiz mishima
idea podemos hacerla en estas
expresiones factor izando actualizamos x
cuadrado como x + 3 por x menos 3 es una
diferencia de cuadrados y x cuadrada más
5 x + 6
eso es x2 x x 3 y en efecto pues 2 x 3 6
2 + 13 5
es justo lo que queremos entonces el
denominador común debe tener que pues
como ya hacemos vamos a borrar esto de
acá pero vamos a seguir la idea de eso
el denominador común necesita pues de
estos factores que va aquí abajo
entonces esto es igual
entonces nuestro denominador común
necesita necesita una x más 3
necesitan un x3 lo ponemos una x + 3
pues ya eso se hace cargo de fx más 3
también necesitamos ahora un x3
meditamos un x3 lo ponemos aquí x menos
y necesitamos una x + 2 lo ponemos x + 2
y otra forma en la que se puede pensar
esto es observar que deben aparecer
todos los factores de esta cosa de por
acá que es x + 3 y x menos 3 ahí están y
también debe de tener todos los factores
de x + 2 x x + 3 ya está el x + 3
entonces invitamos a nada más a añadir
un x + 2
y pues eso es lo que obtenemos como
denominador común
este es el denominador común más pequeño
ahora si este es el denominador común
que tenemos que hacer para cambiar
nuestras prácticas las fracciones voy a
va a reescribir esto un poco más aquí
abajo entonces qué hacemos para cambiar
este 1 entre x descuadradas bueno déjame
escribirlo como x más 3 x x 3
entonces esto de aquí y de aquí son lo
mismo entonces como esta cosa necesita
un x + 2
debemos multiplicarlo arriba y abajo x x
+ 2 y + 2 x + 2 y estoy aquí esta
expresión que es la misma que está en la
primera tenemos se convierte en un x + 2
/ x + 3 x x menos 3 x x 2
entonces estos x + 2 se cancelarían y
regresamos a la expresión original
entonces este este es el primer término
el primer sumando el de acá
este término del otro lado el segundo el
2 entre entre x + 2 por x + 3
qué es la factorización de esto de acá
pues queremos que le aparezca un x3 y si
queremos que aparezca ese x3 debemos de
dividir entre x menos 3 pero también en
el numerador hay que poner un x menos 3
entonces bueno esto es básicamente
multiplicar el numerador y el
denominador por x menos tres haciendo
esto queda 12 x menos 6 dividido entre
x2 x x más 3 por x menos 3
entonces este segundo término el segundo
sumando es lo mismo que este de acá que
esta expresión aquí abajo
entonces ya podemos sumarlas porque
tienen el denominador como ya tienen el
mismo denominador un poquito cambiado en
orden pero es lo mismo que es este que
está aquí arriba entonces esta expresión
esta primera la ponemos aquí como x + 2
x + 2 se cancela con el x más dócil y
efectivamente es el primer término que
está por acá
y a eso tenemos que sumarle hay que
sumarle un 2 x menos 6
y pues sí o sea justo concuerda que el 2
x 6 con lo que estábamos haciendo con lo
que calculamos aquí abajo porque pues o
sea si nos fijamos esto es como un 2 x
menos 3 que si se cancela con el x menos
tres de abajo obtenemos la expresión
original esto es justo esto es lo que
queremos esto de aquí es igual vamos a
hacer ahora si la operación esto es
igual a 3 x 2 menos 6 es menos 4 y
dividido dividido entre nuestro
denominador
podemos multiplicarlo o algo pero vamos
a dejarlo multiplicando vamos a ponerlo
x + 3 por x 3 por x + 2 y listo